yesterday I told you about Ted Cruz and
his 2012 hurricane sandy hypocrisy he
did not want to support a bill in 2012
for hurricane sandy relief he does now
want federal funding federal relief
funds for hurricane Harvey relief and as
is often the case the truth is not only
slightly different than what
ideologically committed Republicans
often say it very often is the total
opposite and David Sirota who's a friend
of the show a former guest on the
program he wrote a really good piece in
the International Business Times and he
pointed out that Republicans have
historically taken advantage of
hurricanes to justify doing more fossil
fuel drilling and harvesting and you'll
often hear the right whenever there's a
natural disaster they'll say you know
this isn't the time to talk about
climate change this isn't the time to
talk about the effect of humans on our
climate even though it's actually
perfectly reasonable to be talking about
climate change all the time including
after natural disasters but recall what
Republicans did after Hurricane Katrina
Hurricane Katrina crippled oil and gas
infrastructure and Republicans after
Hurricane Katrina took that as an
opportunity to argue hey we need more
oil and gas drilling all over the
country so that in the future we would
be less impacted by oil and gas
infrastructure that gets damaged by
hurricanes what we should be saying is
well let's get off of fossil fuels
altogether and shift to renewables so we
don't have to worry at all about
hurricanes impacting fossil fuel
installations but no Republicans said we
should do more oil and gas drilling and
what you have to realize is that if we
have hurricanes Republicans will say we
need more oil and gas drilling if we
don't have hurricanes
Republicans will say this is a great
time to do more oil and gas drilling
because the installations won't be at
risk of being destroyed by hurricanes
that's the key issue no matter what is
going on with climate or weather or the
environment
publicans will argue that we need more
oil and gas drilling and I will not be
surprised Pat to hear the exact same
thing in the wake of Hurricane Harvey
and Republicans are supposed to be
champions for just the best idea winning
out in the free market whatever's best
for Humanity maybe even the environment
or just whatever is going to be most
profitable and yet it seems like they're
favoring specific industries and oil
that are non-renewable resources like
oil and gas and coal totally I mean coal
is the best example Trump wanting to
single-handedly revived an industry that
has fewer employees than Arby's
nationally that is falling out of favor
as a result of market conditions and
technological conditions and
environmental conditions to some degree
and he wants to force that in even
though he claims to be for the free
market and the best possible outcome of
any hurricane that is hugely destructive
and has led to so much tragedy the wake
of week of which is is going to be
observed for a long time in the tech in
various parts of Texas is that we should
start putting together the big picture
right economic inequality in terms of
people's ability to weather such a storm
in a literal sense here climate change
science the Commons energy there is a
lot here but doing more drilling for oil
and gas is absolutely the last thing
that we should be coming away with and
we need to be prepared don't be shocked
when you start hearing Republicans say
we should strengthen our oil and gas
infrastructure to make us less
susceptible to interruptions in energy
supply as a result of these hurricanes
that is the wrong approach I've been
talking about it for years you probably
already understand that but get ready
for the Republican double speak on it
discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum at david pakman.com
slash reddit today's program sponsored
in part by tag adapt the hosting
specialist whether you need dedicated
server solutions virtual private servers
cloud server options custom server
solutions colocation services whatever
you need for your business or project
tag a DAB and their expert hosting
specialists and support will set you up
with what works for your business or
project and their hosting services
support a really wide range of customers
and businesses around the world
including bloggers tech startups
financial traders gamers web developers
and more you can use the code TDPS
20 to get a 20 british pound credit
towards cloud server options at signup
tag adapt calm /td PS with that you can
try out their services and save 20
British pounds about 23 24 US dollars
you use the code TDPS 20 at sign up ta
ga da b.com /t dps check it out